[Musique]
bonjour nouveau débat sur tv 78
également sur radio sensations dans le
cadre du premier tour des élections
municipales
aujourd'hui consacré à l encours trois
listes sont déclarés au 8 février à
l'élan cours porté par jean michel
fourgous maire sortant réinventons
elancourt porté par catherine perrotin
raufast et et l'on course et vous porter
par un michel rossi bonjour à tous les
trois au cours de ce débat le temps de
parole sera chronométrée afin d'assurer
au mieux l'égalité entre chacun et nous
débutons comme pour tous les autres
débats avec ce premier tour de table
avec une question pourquoi vous
présenter à ce scrutin est pourquoi les
électeurs devraient vous choisir vous
avez une minute une minute trente chacun
pour répondre ensuite nous passerons aux
thématiques
nous débutons avec jean michel fourgous
et l'ordre qui a été décidé par tirage
au sort juste avant que nous prenions
l'antenne et ce sera l'un vers ce pour
la conclusion tout à l'heure jean michel
fourgous vous êtes maire sortant élu
pour la première fois en 96 vous êtes
aussi le président sortant de saint
quentin en yvelines sur le plan
politique adhérents les républicains
avec une liste ouverte pour ce scrutin
donc cette question pourquoi vous
présentez cette fois ci est pourquoi les
électeurs devraient choisir votre liste
parce que je suis passionné par
l'encours d'un certain temps mes enfants
ils sont nés et ont grandi
j'ai fait j'ai développé des projets
d'une certaine ça donne un pack même
nationale partir d'elancourt c'est un
espèce de mélange quand même assez
équilibré entre le champ de ville à la
campagne
et puis et puis des beaux projets en
plus avec même au niveau économique ans
j'ai une culture un peu plus économique
peut-être que par la classe politique
traditionnelle mais d'avoir aujourd'hui
là ce qu'on appelle la sky high tech qui
est elle en cours c'est-à-dire toute la
partie les faits de saint pierre où il y
a les plus belles boîtes du monde en
fait en vo vous avez un niveau 2 de
compétences de très haute valeur ajoutée
qui est à dire cordes et en france toute
cette culture numérique ou cette
révolution numérique effectivement ils
encourent se retrouve donc au coeur de
tout cela et puis et puis bien sûr vous
et des projets extraordinaires enfin on
voit maintenant que l encore devient un
site olympique
ce qui va permettre effectivement de
tester en harmonie avec les jo
puis sur demande pousser un projet très
écologique peut-être certainement grâce
aussi à opio grâce qui était avec lille
le loisir en plus ce qui est juste à
côté où ça fait des années qu'on cherche
un projet donc pas moi faire un parc une
sorte de parc est venu à central park de
central park un avec ses trois sites
olympiques vélo en dehors du golfe et
vraiment ça ça c'est une je pense
qu'elle en cours il ya un vivier
extraordinaire des forces vives et puis
j'ai une équipe formidable ce qui ma
compagne mon plein de bonnes choses qui
qui vous donne envie de faire bouger les
choses de faire réussir les gens parce
que on est là pour faire réussir les
autres et nous développons ces
différentes thématiques au cours du
débat dans quelques instants catherine
perron tinrent face de vous mener une
liste soutenue par génération le parti
socialiste le parti communiste europe
écologie et nouvelle donne a notamment
on retrouve aussi des élus de l'actuelle
opposition sur votre liste même question
pourquoi vous présentez et pourquoi les
électeurs devraient vous choisir alors
effectivement nous sommes une liste
soutenue par l'ensemble des partis de
gauche et écologique
mais la majorité des colistiers ne sont
pas inscrits
un parti politique nous sommes une liste
citoyenne et participative nous avons
construit notre projet avec les
habitants d'el en cours notamment au
cours de trois réunions thématiques au
mois de janvier
nous sommes motivés par un profond désir
de renouvellement à la mairie
d'elancourt après 24 ans à la mairie le
maire a une vision dépassée pour la
ville qui n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux écologiques et sociétaux actuels
et nous proposons sur notre programme
une ville plus solidaire une ville plus
festive une ville qui crée des liens
entre les habitants
une ville qui aura un engagement
écologique fort est une ville qui
propose à la mairie une nouvelle
démocratie participative une ville plus
transparentes sur sa gestion
donc par exemple nous parlons accès aux
soins de santé pour les avants courtois
mutuelle de village on aura le temps de
développer maison de santé maisons
médicales de garde
nous parlons circulation 12 nous parlons
réaménagement de la zone artisanale des
quatre arbres préservation et
valorisation des espaces naturels de la
ville et faire participer les élans
courtois au projet de la ville dernière
candidate déclarée sur la commune
d'hallencourt c'est michel rossi vous
vous êtes la dernière a déclaré
justement vous avez été investi par la
république en marche
tout à fait notre ambition de l'ensemble
de notre liste c'est de faire revivre et
l'encours de redynamiser de développer
l'attractivité d'elancourt il y a
effectivement des points forts dont ils
encourent mais qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui exploités et c'est vraiment
ce que regrette l'ensemble de la liste
donc moi même j'ai été investi par la
république en marche je mène une liste
citoyenne avec des personnes qui ont des
sensibilités politiques diverses aussi
bien de gauche du parti socialistes et
radicaux de gauche proche du centre
proche du mouvement de valérie pécresse
également adhérent en marche et une
majorité de listiers qui n'ont pas
d'étiquette parce que notre volonté ce
n'est pas de mes traîné
et dans notre liste mais bien de porter
un projet de prendre en compte le
quotidien des citoyens pour bâtir le
vide de demain et nous avons parlé des
différentes thématiques à présent
première thématique sur les grands
projets il ya plusieurs dossiers que
nous allons aborder
on va commencer avec vous michel rossi
vous avez été un peu plus courte sur la
présentation vous avez un peu plus de
retard force forcément parlons pour
débuter de l'aménagement paris 2024 vous
en avez parlé tout à l'heure jean michel
fourgous elancourt ville olympique c'est
en tout cas le projet qui a été retenu
avec paris 2024 pour accueillir les
épreuves de vtt sur cette colline des
longs cours seulement il semble en tout
cas que les instances olympiques serait
encore en train de se poser des
questions des questions d'aménagement
notamment sur sept sur sept collines
d'ici la fin de l'année 2020 seront
définitivement fixé la ville de chamonix
également souhaité récupérer ces
épreuves
ce qui n'a pas été sans agacer le maire
sortant d'ailleurs on aura l'occasion
d'y revenir
mais quel est votre positionnement avoue
une chaleur aussi sur ce dossier
l'aménagement paris 2024 et sur la
colline d'elancourt cette colline
d'elancourt doit accueillir ces épreuves
de vtt il n'est pas question de remettre
en cause ce projet ou celle inverse
non alors nous nous sommes pour
effectivement on ne peut pas à la fois
avoir la volonté développer
l'attractivité d'une ville et nier
l'intérêt de ce type d'épreuve
par contre il est évident qu'on se met
dans un système d'organisation jo éco
responsable c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a
fait le partenariat entre le cojo et
puis wf france comité olympique ou alors
effectivement garantir des jeux
éco-responsable donc à cette condition
nous nous inscrivons pleinement dans ce
projet ce que je tiens à dire aux
citoyens c'est que toutefois les projets
de construction sur le sommet de la
colline ne sont absolument pas
nécessaire au bon déroulement de ces
jeux olympiques
donc l'idée du globe ou d'un restaurant
panoramique dont aucun lien
courrier du ministère le confirme n'ont
aucune incidence sur le fait que la
colline soit ou non retenus pour ce site
je tiens même à dire que si
effectivement la colline n'était pas
retenu pour le site
nous souhaitons un aménagement avec une
piste vtt ce qui sécurisera les
vététistes tout en permettant aux femmes
il de continuer à effectuer des
randonnées sur la colline il est donc
tout à fait possible de rendre cette
colline aux aidants pour toi en
améliorant d'ailleurs le site un terme
de propreté en sécurisant et en faisant
tout à fait des animations au sommet on
peut y mettre aussi une table
d'orientation qui permettrait aux
personnes de mieux appréhender
l'environnement dans laquelle deux se
situent juste une précision vous est-il
la ville n'était pas retenu pour
l'instant elle a été retenue quand elle
était dans le dossier qui a été déposée
elle a été retenu malgré la volonté
notamment de chamonix de récupérer les
est vrai qu'elle a été présenté le
dossier
mais je rappelle que monsieur tony
estanguet a dit qu'il y avait encore
justement des soucis environnementaux à
prendre en compte et la décision finale
n'est pas encore prise elle ne sera
prise avant la fin de l'année
catherine bertin vos propositions pour
cette colline des longs cours et ce
dossier déjà paris 2024 oui ou non pour
elle encourt alors la décision ne nous
appartient pas de dire si elancourt à
accueillera au palais les épreuves de
vtt
la décision sera bientôt prise nous ce
que nous souhaitons c'est effectivement
que cela ne conduise pas à un bétonnage
de la colline c'est très important pour
nous que la colline reste un espace
végétalisé qui accueillera effectivement
des possibilités de promenades deux
circuits de vtt une colline qui soient
aménagés pour les familles et les élans
courtois voilà pour votre votre regard
si vous souhaitez développer plus vous
pouvez je rappelle que le temps de
parole et est chronométré vous souhaitez
prendre une quinzaine secondes pour
répondre à cette question il n'y a aucun
souci
jean michel fourgous sur cette colline
d'elancourt vous êtes montré avec les
différentes représentativité ce soit
régions départements et autres plutôt
agacé de cette éventuelle remise en
cause
oui alors des morts sept collines élan
course avait 40 ans
que tout le monde s'engueule
régulièrement pour le projet entre à
l'époque c'était l'agglomération qui
était pas les mêmes couleurs variées les
projets sur dont les pistes de ski dont
le restaurant ça dont le globe
au dessus il ya une telle proposition
aucune pour l'instant n'a été choisi
mais d'ailleurs ça montre bien que ça
fait fantasmer beaucoup d'eau et
architectes formellement refusé par les
landes je me souviens pas qu'il y ait eu
un référendum sur inferno cissé
d'elancourt alors alors ça c'est
intéressant
la déco l'est aussi et qui vous a amené
a finalement abandonné ce projet colle
et qui était très coûteux écologie mme
catherine perron sur la commune de là
encore je laisserais d'un
conventionnement donald ne confondez pas
il faut écouter tout le monde c'est
quand on est maire est nécessairement
mais ne confondez pas un une
représentation une représentativité une
démocratie participative est une
démocratie représentative
tout ce qui est un groupement partie
bâti bon on voit un collectif comme vous
venez de dire deux trois quatre cinq dix
personnes qui se monte sur 26 mille
personnes bon dire où un collectif a
décidé que ça se passe pas comme ça
demain si vous avez des responsabilités
vous n'allez pas céder à chaque fois
vous avez une centaine de collectifs qui
vont se créer sur votre sur chaque
mandat de chaque maire attention donc ça
voilà on écoute tout le monde ne sait
pas
un collectif il ya un collectif qui
était monté avec un président le goût du
collectif qui était venu dans une fois
par an simplement sur la colline et il
habitait guyancourt là et puis vdd jean
caby t'es même pas en france qu'elle
essayait de quoi bon mais cela dit gars
ont le sens de l'humour
revenons la colline elancourt c'est plus
de 50 ha c'est la colline est plus élevé
de france bien sûr qu'il faut un beau
projet fort mais pas uniquement
monopolisé par un collectif de quelques
dizaines de personnes il faut que tous
les élans courtois là dessus bien sûr
s'exprime pour l'instant c'est léger ou
qui ont été choisis il faut aussi un
aménagement écologique parce
qu'aujourd'hui les gens le demandent
il faut que quand vous êtes noir vous
devez
être à l écoute pas uniquement de l'un
ou de l'autre ou d'un collectif assez
l'ensemble c'est ce que vous sentez
quand vous êtes maire avec tous les
moyens que vous avez d'entrer dans
l'achat de votre population
il faut un beau projet en accord avec le
cio en accord avec la région aussi parce
que derrière on va construire on va
élaborer en tout cas un pain un espèce
de projets de parcs sport santé nature
loisirs et qui va en fait être cohérent
avec lille de loisirs 600 hectares la
plus belle île de loisirs l'île de
france avec le bassin d'eau de 130
hectares aussi faim donc tout ça il faut
trouver un projet commun cohérent il
faut faire travailler tout le monde là
dessus mais voilà de grâce
il ya les choses ne sont rien n'était
arrêté il ya des tas d'idées qui
m'arrive tous les matins je vais pas
vous en faire lice et c'est formidable
ça fait ça fait que ça fait déjà une
très belle publicité à willencourt je
remercie tous ceux qui ont pas voilà
voilà et rappelez vous que ces 5
milliards d'individus qui une fois non
non dans votre vie vous regarde regarde
un peu aussi les valeurs du sport et
lors du sport on en a bien besoin c'est
c'est l'esprit d'équipé c'est le respect
de l'autre le respect de l'arbitré
et tout ça bien sûr toutes ces valeurs
nous intéresse de biens il diffusait
aussi sur l encours et sur les villes
environ puis quatre autres civils et le
projet est juste après je vous passe les
projets pharaoniques porté par jean
michel fourgous pour la colline tel
qu'un restaurant panoramique ou une
espèce de grosse boule connectés
n'apporteront aucun aucune plus value
aux élans courtois il est en cours toi
refusent ces projets eux ce qu'ils
veulent c'est un aménagement de la
colline qui soient écologiques
végétalisée complètement qui soit pour
les familles ni de loisirs de cyclisme
ils n'ont pas intérêt à ce que la ville
soit vu par 5 milliard d'habitants ça ne
leur apportera rien du tout cher aussi
je pense qu'effectivement ce regard au
moment des jeux olympiques peut-être
mondial mais après il ya le quotidien
des gens donc qui ne va pas construire
quelque chose sur la colline juste
pendant la durée des jeux olympiques
les élans courtois veulent pouvoir
profiter au quotidien régulièrement de
cette colline et c'est très bien d'avoir
des tas d'idées et régulièrement des
idées nouvelles mais il faut aussi qu'on
affiche les choses de manière
transparente les ayants courtoise
attendent des informations précises
je parlerai juste l'exemple de combien
on doit raser d'arbres alors on est
parti de 4000 à une cérémonie des voeux
on a attendu quarante mille et je crois
qu au dernier conseil municipal
on est à une vingtaine d'arbres donc là
aussi on aimerait dans le cadre de la
démocratie être plus clairement informés
des sûr c'est la roja quelqu'un disait
je crois sur l'intérieur et on en
replante de confondre avec le fait qu'on
implante 5000 arbres et je crois qu'ils
veulent c'est bon là c'est le cio qui
veut éventuellement coupé 20 et qui ne
sont de faible qualité que le gym s'est
passionné je vous invite à écouter la
bande des voeux des seniors autre grand
projet d'aménagement qui occupera cette
prochaine mandature à elancourt pour
le/la prochain maire de cette commune
c'est le commissariat aussi commissariat
du futur c'est un projet lié à paris
2024 en quelque sorte projet de
commissariats qui a été lancé en 2005
qui a reçu en 2010 9 l'année dernière
l'agrément de l'état qui regroupera les
effectifs d'elancourt trappe et
guyancourt
avant de vous repassez la parole jean
michel fourgous vous avez beaucoup
d'avancé il vous aurait sans doute des
choses à dire sur ce commissariat et
j'aimerais vous entendre catherine
perrotin raufast vous avaient le plus de
retard 2 minutes 50 de temps de parole
j'aimerais vous entendre sur ce projet
de commissariats le faire pas le
réaliser revenir dessus autres quel est
le positionnement votre liste pour les
élans courtoise et les élans courtois
effectivement nous pensons que les
conditions actuelles du commissariat
d'elancourt son
très défavorable à l'exercice de leur
métier pour les policiers le
commissariat est très très dégradée donc
il faut un nouveau commissariat le
commissariat d'agde l'eau qui doit être
construit nous pensons que il doit être
construit ailleurs que là où c'est prévu
parce que l'endroit qui a été choisi par
jean michel fourgous est un endroit où
ce commissariat va apporter énormément
de nuisance au centre de la ville des
nuisances sonores des nuisances
visuelles
nous ne savons pas comment les 350
fonctionnaires qui vont ils travailler
vont pouvoir se garer
nous n'avons pas réussi à obtenir de
réponse à cette question au conseil
municipal du mois de décembre
nous pensons qu'il y à d'autres endroits
dans l'intercommunalité pour construire
ce commissariat qui sera un commissariat
intercommunale j'ai des idées si vous
voulez je vous les donnerais donc ses
discours non c'est pas du tout du disco
dit le prix j'ai les idées dit que c'est
pas bien là alors c'est bien alors par
exemple vous pouvez trouver des friches
notamment dans la zone industrielle il y
à des endroits où le commissariat serait
très bien je ne vois vraiment pas
pourquoi il faut qu'il soit en centre
ville d'elancourt
les riverains n'ont pas du tout envie
d'avoir toutes ces nuisances
il est actuellement le seul autre place
sans trop de là où vous voulez le mettre
il y aura 350 professionnels
oui évidemment que j'ai c'est vilain
monsieur foule à elancourt l'actuel
commissariat
michel rossi alors sur ce commissariat
il est évident que comme beaucoup
malheureusement debaty il n'y a pas eu
d'entretien de ce commissariat et les
conditions de travail sont ils sont
déplorables ça je pense que tout le
monde que tu en être d'accord donc c'est
important de faire évoluer de donner des
conditions trahi tout à fait décente et
efficace aux forces de l'ordre après se
pose effectivement la question ce
commissariat je lirai il est un peu
ils se baladent ce qu'il ya un moment
donné c'était envisagé sur les jardins
familiaux
il y a eu là aussi une pétition est donc
finalement nommé plus là on envisage à
sion on envisage pour ça que pour les
pétitions mais on tient compte de tous
mais ceci dit les lignes haute tension
elles sont visibles et enfouir des
niveaux de tension ou alors il y a un
problème de d'appréhension du projet
c'est évident ça coûte de l'argent
15 millions d'euros dont 5 pris en
charge par rte reste un delta de 10
après on envisage du coup de les mettre
à la place des terrains de tennis
ce qui d'ailleurs dit on permettra de
les rénover
sentant qu'il ya aussi empreint de
dégradation ces équipements il peut y
avoir aussi bien sûr il en cours puisque
je rappelle qu'à côté du commissariat
actuelle il ya le pp est celle qui est
quasiment vide
donc il pourrait y avoir une réflexion
sur cette zone il peut y avoir
effectivement des friches attrape
puisqu'il se trouve que ça couvrant
plusieurs communes il déjà connu ce
saignement à l enfant aussi on remplace
on remplace le commercial il encourt qui
est obsolète
voilà intercommunale mais qui va le
commissariat de l'agglo il s'appelle des
lèvres selon mme il intègre les trois
cols les quatre commissariats même avec
celui çi gilles rappelle que le
commissariat
michel forget en russie cette agence ait
pas double s'appelle que le commissariat
supplément à elancourt couvre à peu près
une centaine de personnes donc là aussi
on a eu des informations à géométrie
variable du mieux c est ce que ce futur
commissariat regroupera bien 350
personnes la coordination d'autres sous
la coordination de 300
regarde les trois commissaires lui en
courtes rappelle encore s'agissait pas d
supprimés et donc à combien de personnes
effectivement va profiter ce
commissariat
il ya une photo qui circule depuis peu
près une quinzaine d'années ça
m'interpelle puisqu'il n'y a pas eu
encore d'appels à projets donc
l'architecte n'est pas défini donc
est-ce que c'est purement un plaisir
d'imaginer cette instance avec notamment
un héliport donc effectivement bonjour
ce commissariat il alors cela dit ce
futur la sécurité c'est une des
premières attentes d'abord des français
d elancourt thouars faut le rappeler
deuxièmement ce comice à est vraiment
obsolète je pense que vous n'avez pas
tous d'accord c'est pas humain de faire
travailler les policiers il ya une
certaine de police est en cours
350 sur les trois commissaires bon ça
fonctionne pas on n'arrive pas à réunir
les trois commissaires pour une réunion
tentant il faudrait mieux commune c'est
dramatique
donc il faut faire quelque chose on peut
continuer à parler ces communes sur la
colline
il y avait un projet qui sont arrivés
marocains d'ailleurs pour l'instant ni
retenue il faut intégrer qu'aujourd'hui
il ya une révolution technologique aux
miss à l'intérieur ils ont dit
d'ailleurs saint-quentin et laon cours
et l'encours est obsolète il faut il
faut effectivement faciliter un projet
modèle qui intègre vraiment toutes les
dernières technologies pour pour
garantir la qualité qualité des
conditions de travail de nos policiers
et est aussi le soin des victimes parce
que quand vous portez plainte que tout
le monde écoute ses parfums les
conditions de travail ne sont pas du
tout non donc il s'agit en d'améliorer
la qualité de vie
malheureusement tout individu est
susceptible sur la violence c'est la
première injustice en france il faut
vraiment là dessus être un modèle à
elancourt alors maintenant vous l'avez
compris c'est pas par rapport à une
pétition quoi que ce soit
c'est que yes et qu'on peut pas faire
fonctionner akomissa de ce niveau de
modernité avec des lignes haute tension
au dessus je pense qu'on est tous
compris bon et puis le prix s'il s'agit
sur le saut ce fameux projet deux des
quatre armes si déjà il faut mettre 15
millions pour pour lancer le moindre
projet on est de choisir un moment donné
il y avait il y avait beaucoup de
projets effectivement c'est celui qui
était différée voilà me sera fait mais
il a été différé ma faim merkel comme
issa c'est urgent la demande enfin après
dix ans on a obtenu les moyens avec des
partenaires aussi importants autour de
nous je le dire que bon y'a pas photo je
pense que dire l'isolant contrôleur vous
parlez donc que vous savez ce que
pensent tous les élan pour toi bon moi
je ne sais pas je je les vois quand même
très souvent tu es plus souvent vous bon
sachez qu'il ya une forte attente sur ce
commissariat pas il n'y a pas de
discussions et ils sont d'accord a
poussé les les terrains de tennis ya
aucun problème surtout que c'est
l'occasion de leur faire jean-michel
fond rouge et noir vont interrompre
votre temps paroles s'envolent vous êtes
à plus d'une minute
catherine perrotin si vous souhaitez
réagir sur ce sujet je trouve que le
maire d'elancourt est extrêmement vague
qui ne connaît pas le dossier qu'il ne
nous présente rien de précis par rapport
à ce qu'on ait saria tableau rien n'est
précis douze des plus précises c'est
vous-même ou ségolène mais vous avez
porté un projet et vous n'êtes vous êtes
incapables de nous l'expliquer vous êtes
extrêmement vague
écoutez je ne savais pas que j'allais
vite vous ne savez pas combien il y aura
de fonctionner à coutras 24 millions
yahia il ya trois financeurs et vous le
savez très bien c'était dit il faut que
je peux vous le dire je connais par
coeur tous deux dossiers mais je veux
l'agent peut on peut parler du nombre de
policiers ces 350 pour une corneille à
une ouverture sur plaisir mais c'est pas
décidé pour l'instant parce que tous les
commissariats bien sûr sont intéressés
ils savent très bien
ces moyens vont intéresser tous les
commissariats il faut il faut fixer le
périmètre c'est à l'étude avec le préfet
à ça des plumes la tension de critiques
de calomnies voilà vous connaissez très
bientôt si vous avez lu man x
je me suis exprimé sur ce projet
franchement soyez sincères vous gagnerez
du temps et du crédit vis-à-vis de ces
fameuses il encore temps que vous
connaissez beaucoup mieux que
jean-michel fois où je vous arrête
catherine perrotin raufast vous
souhaitez et j'ai à faire des
propositions on vous écoute vous avez
plus de temps de parole en retard donc
allez-y mais si vous relancez les autres
commissariats dans l'humour est obsolète
il faut un nouveau commissariat pour
elancourt un nouveau commissariat pour
l'intercommunalité il faut le mettre
ailleurs que sur les tennis d'elancourt
je ne vous ai pas soyons les friches
soyez priso la zone industrielle je suis
calme que gelée du frij de quelle la
zone industrielle alors qu'il ya déjà un
commissariat je vous laisse étudié avec
moi je suis arrivé j'ai aussi suivi j'ai
rajouté interview son récit géo mais il
vous plaît je vous propose un rendez
vous il nous en parlerons méchant
conscience que quelques secondes et nous
passerons au dessus j'ai juste rajouté
qu'il a été évoqué que ce commissariat
du futur à l'écouté en haut un milieu
aux élans courtois ça m'interpelle parce
que ces terrains ont été mis
gratuitement à disposition on va dire à
l'euro symbolique
néanmoins quand on sait que la vente des
terrains sur pau nicolau rapporter 3
millions à la commune ça m'interpelle
qu'ils émigrent aux deux andy naze
lionel tarak donc on peu importe ce
qu'on a fait c'est juste le problème
d'évaluer le coût du terrain pour la
construction du commissariat je pense
que là il ya vraiment une erreur de
calcul continue à parler des différents
enjeux sur ce scrutin sur la ville
d'elancourt avec ce débat qui se
poursuit
un dernier des grands projets nous
passerons ensuite sur la vie quotidienne
en essayant de gagner un petit peu de
temps les uns et les autres pour pouvoir
aborder les différents sujets au cours
de cette heure global d'émission est un
autre sujet qui concerne la ville de
maurepas également puisque les deux
villes se sont associés autour du une
piscine intercommunale l'ancienne
piscine de maurepas a été fermée vous le
savez pour des raisons de sécurité la
nouvelle piscine intercommunale doit
s'installer au même endroit une date de
livraison a été annoncée 2022
les le 17 décembre les conseils
municipaux de maurepas et des longs
cours ont approuvé le projet retenu est
ce que vous reviendrez si vous êtes élu
catherine perrotin en faste sur ce sur
ce projet alors
la ville de maurepas et la ville
d'elancourt ont laissé se dégrader
l'ancienne piscine au fil des années il
n'y a pas eu de rénovation l'ont laissé
se dégrader à tel point qu'il a fallu la
ferme et puis la démolir ensuite du
temps a passé et le projet est
maintenant celui d'un centre aqualudique
au prix très élevé qui est passé en un
an de 16 millions à 24 millions avec une
délégation de service public
ce projet est annoncé d'ailleurs dans le
bulletin municipal avec un coût qui est
faux puisque nous savons que ce coût va
être pour la ville d'elancourt de 3
millions dans un premier temps et
ensuite de 480 mille euros par an
pendant 25 ans on l'habille dis donc à
12 plus trg 12 millions +3 millions la
ville d'elancourt et l'esprit
fonctionnaires ville de mort pas au bout
des 25 en seront propriétaire d'un
centre aquatique dans quel état
sera-t-il à ce moment là nous n'avons
pas pu obtenir le contrat qui a été
passé avec eiffage puisqu'il y a eu là
un déni de démocratie
les élus municipaux d'opposition n'ont
pas pu obtenir ce contrat
donc nous ne savons rien sur l'état dans
lequel au bout de 25 ans la société
eiffage devra livrer le centre aquatique
aux deux villes donc voilà encore une
fois c'est un projet mal géré et mal
conçus opaque pour lequel rien n'a été
demandé aux habitants sur ce qu'ils
souhaitaient puisque le maire parle de
concertation alors qu'il s'agissait de
faire trois clics sur le site de la
ville pour savoir si on voulait un
plongeoir à trois mètres ou un plongeoir
à admettre ça ça n'est pas une
concertation nous quand nous aurons des
projets portés pour la ville surtout
d'un tel coup nous interrogerons les
habitants et nous construirons le projet
avec eux en attendant cela vous fera
huit ans que les enfants d'elancourt
n'auront pas pu apprendre
nager en dehors de toutes les
obligations légales de sécurisation de
la natation positive à cause des villes
de maurepas et d'elancourt qui ont
négligé
l'enquêté de la gestionnaire ses
gestionnaires c'est uniquement maurepas
qui est égyptien mais vous causer à
bozar ce que vous n'avez pas réussi à
passer la piscine à l'intercommunalité
alors que c'était l'idée que vous aviez
derrière michel rossi c'est à vous jean
michel fourgous ensuite alors moi
j'aimerais faire de grandes remarques
sur ce projet oui il est évident qu'il
faut absolument que les enfants les
associations et tous les élans courtois
est une piscine maintenant clairement
nous n'aurions pas gérer ce dossier de
cette façon à la fois d'un point de vue
coût sur les coûts d'entretien annuel de
300 à 400 mille euros concernant les
élans courtois nous aurions pu
sérieusement réduire la donne tout
simplement en construisant une piscine
et sur mort papou et l'encouragement pas
nous aurions d'ailleurs peut-être du
coup récupérer quoi nièvre qui a quitté
ce projet démesuré et en basculant
l'activité ludique sur la fameuse île de
loisirs qui peine justement à être un
peu équilibrée financièrement donc nous
aurions pu avoir ces deux projets
répondre à la nécessité scolaire je
rappelle que c'est obligatoire
l'apprentissage de la natation donc
répondre à ce cette obligation répondre
aux associations aux besoins de tous les
élans courtois est néanmoins permettre
aux familles de bénéficier d'une
activité ludique sur l'île de loisirs
nous aurions pu faire les deux mais vous
voyez bien que dans un cas le montant à
la charge démord pas et un des élans
courtois aurait été sérieusement
diminuée puisque sur l'île de loisirs
c'est la communauté d'agglo est le
département qui aurait géré ses frais
d'entretien ça c'est le premier point
le second point c'est que l'arrêt brutal
de cette piscine a été très mal pris en
compte
on a
rien fait pour permettre aux élèves de
bénéficier des cours de natation
moi j'aimerais juste interrogé monsieur
bruce de savoir s'il sait combien il ya
eu de noyades accidentelles d'enfants en
255 c'est plus qu'en 2015 en rapport
avec la fermeture de la piscine de nos
repas vous affirmer sa jeudi en rapport
au fait que pour ses enfants
il est absolument indispensable de leur
apprendre à nager ce qui les sécurise
tous et que évidemment et oui monsieur
mais dans ces cas là il ya des choix à
faire en mode de gestion sur l'exercice
2014 2019
on installe 2300 tablette mais c'est pas
avec une tablette qu'on sait apprendre à
nager
nous n'aurions pas fait ses choix
budgétaires et sur les deux ans qui
restent c'est l'ouverture n'est pas
retarder encore une fois nous ne serons
pas ses choix jean michel fourgous et à
vous sur ce dossier piscine je sais
qu'on est contraint par le temps et qui
a beaucoup de choses à dire mais si vous
pouviez en une minute une minute trente
revenir sur ce dossier très rapidement
votre positionnement on a déjà développé
sur notre antenne plus d'une fois ce
dossier de la piscine
aujourd'hui c'est un dossier que vous
allez continuer à accélérer enfin si
vous êtes si si vous êtes réélu bon la
pression la piscine
elle est fermée pour un manque
d'entretien et au jeu des packs aux
gestionnaires peuvent contrairement ce
que nous dit
deuxièmement après il a fallu trouver 50
% des moyens financiers à l'extérieur ce
que j'ai fait et je pense que mon
intervention a pas du tout cas été je
pense sur l'ensemble des gens concernés
donc c'est plus que 50 % pied
troisièmement vous confondez les frais
de fonctionnement le déficit de toutes
les piscines de france comme les
patinoires c'est elles sont toutes des
cités c'est entre 400 mille sept cent
mille jusqu'à me voilà donc vous
confondez un peu les choses
donc de toutes façons et et maurepas et
elancourt depuis son compte à un pays où
ils auraient eu bon à payer ce site
dernier point vous dites que vous
contestez le modèle de gestion ça c'est
très politique idéologique on vous
connaît
certes un bon voilà je vous rappelle que
la cour des comptes je crois prescrit
bien dit que c'est le modèle le plus
viable
actuellement donc c'est par la cour des
comptes excusez moi c'est la cour des
comptes qui dit ça que c'est le modèle
le plus viable actuellement pour faire
fonctionner signe alors en plus haut
savoir qu' il ya beaucoup de piscines
qui sont obsolètes et on va se retrouver
à l'agglomération de saint quentin à
prendre en charge ça et je pense que
c'est un modèle de bonne gestion
d'autant plus quand vous allez
partenaires puissants qui sont
intervenus pour bien sûr partagé en deux
le coup c4n perrotin les villes voisines
qui ont un projet à peu près équivalent
ou la piscine coûte beaucoup moins cher
c'est bien j'adore vos solutions cds ce
que des morts elles sont quand même
assez imprécise elles sont jamais fondé
sur une expérience qu'on n'est pas les
défunts si vous avez le droit mais c'est
mignot monde est imminente vous écouter
ses sept services en jeu propose de
poursuivre ce débat avec une autre
thématique pour qu'on ait le temps tout
abordé reste un peu moins de 30 minutes
d'émission parlant de la vie quotidienne
aussi même si ce dossier de piscine en
faisait finalement partie parlons
démocratie locale aussi c'est l'un des
thèmes retenus là catherine perrotin
débutons avec vous vous avez deux
minutes à peu près de temps de retard en
ce qui concerne la participation la
démocratie locale vous souhaitez
fonctionne et de quelle manière si vous
êtes élu alors si nous sommes élus nous
créerons de des comités de quartier
d'auto ty authentique comité de quartier
qui se réuniront dans chaque comité de
quartier il y aura d'ailleurs un élu de
la ville qui participera et là nous
écouterons les habitants le
nous faire partager leurs besoins qu'ils
ont pour le quartier écouter leurs
propositions et construire avec eux des
projets pour leur quartier il y aura un
budget alloué à ces projets nous aurons
également un budget participatif qui
sera ouvert aux habitants qui auront des
projets plus large a proposé et nous
nous engageons à avoir une transparence
au niveau du budget de la ville a
présenté un budget qui soient claires et
bien définies pour que tous les
habitants sachent de quoi il s'agit au
conseil municipal nous aurons un
fonctionnement en binôme par exemple
comme la tête de liste chez nous et en
binôme je serai maire avec un premier
adjoint nous aurons un travail
équivalent à la mairie et chaque
délégation sera divisé entre deux élus
michel rossi alors pour nous ce point
est un point capital dans notre
programme de même qu'on travaille déjà
dans notre liste en équipe puisque je
vous ai illustrer la différence des
sensibilités politiques et et cette
différence est d'autant plus
intéressante qu'elle de nori nos
échanges et nos débats que nous
construisons notre programme avec des
habitants et au niveau de la démocratie
on la voit à trois niveaux
d'une part on veut changer le mode de
gouvernance il s'agit effectivement de
se dire que vous soyez élu de notre
majorité ou élus de l'opposition tout
avis mérite d'être écouté
nous travaillerons avec l'ensemble des
élus
ça c'est le premier point le second
point c'est effectivement d'associer
tous les quartiers nous essayons d'un
autre liste d'avoir des représentants de
tous les quartiers des encours parce
qu'il y à des problématiques différentes
suivant que vous êtes à la clé saint
pierre aux petits prés où cette mare
vous avez des modes de vie et des
attentes différentes
donc c'est à prendre en compte ça veut
dire qu'avant chaque conseil municipal
un membre de notre municipalité
rencontrera un référent de quartier pour
échanger remonter les informations mais
également lui faire part de l'avancée de
nos travaux nous souhaitons également au
sein de ces comités avoir un référent
écologique pour avancer sur la prise en
compte de l'écologie dans ses différents
quartiers et enfin nous essaierons parce
que la configuration géographique
d'elancourt ne facilite pas les échanges
inter quartiers nous essaierons
également la de rapprocher ses quartiers
avec des événements citoyens mais aussi
par la mise en place de navettes
écologique
nous avons entendu quelques unes des
propositions des candidats jean michel
fourgous concernant la démocratie locale
je les dis quand on est dans
l'opposition on le voit par là que mes
12 mai entre guillemets toutes les
listes d'opposition disent on va
rétablir la démocratie
ok et puis on va faire des missions des
quartiers au nom de cartes x faussaires
quand vous êtes maire je vous souhaite
c'est que vous rencontrez vous avez une
centaine d'événements dans une commune
vous rencontrez un nombre de gens qui
viennent nous voir qui vous exposez
promoteurs vous avez la fête d'automne
nous avait le forum des assos vous avez
la fête de l'acca de saint pierre sur
deux fois autres qui met vous rencontrez
un nom et tous les événements vous avez
plus d'une centaine en plus vous recevez
10000 courrier sur lequel vous répondez
avec des précisions mêmes ou services
les terras vous avez alors monsieur le
maire je suppose connaissez tout c'est
tout c'est vous avez les rentrées
scolaires oui 2000 personnes à peu près
un an les rentrées scolaires
voilà il faut il faut et vous
interrogerez mills senior ou de près de
1000 seniors avec toutes les
manifestations bien sûr que donc
donc voilà il faut il faut il faut
comprendre ça et puis maintenant à
prévoir des résultats le discours c'est
bien mais le résultat c'est mieux
écoutez moi j'ai je dirige aujourd'hui
saint quentin on me l'a demandé j'ai a
priori l'équipe et réunit les douze
quand même fonctionne bien je crois que
ça jamais oui c'est eux-mêmes même même
les gens de gauche le dise que c'est
jamais aussi bien fonctionné on est
reconnu on est au delà des partis on a
on dit vous êtes très partie j'ai eu un
premier papier c'est la gauche contre
agde c'est aujourd'hui
bon il faut être à fond assemblée des
compétences sur la chambre et les forces
vives d'une ville c'est ce qu'on fait
est que ce soit saint quentin où il
encourt bla si voulez des résultats il
faut inspirer confiance pour inspirer
confiance il faut avoir des résultats et
des compétences 70-80 autant si vous
souhaitez répondre pour équilibrer le
temps par vous savez tellement tu veux
travailler en équipe que hier soir vous
n'avez pas pu réunir le comité d'agglo
vous n'avez pas eu de quoi causer des
champions tout sur le terrain
bien sûr ils vont penser que ce n'est
que ça votre campagne ce n'est que de la
calomnie et la désinformation mais
continuer comme ça s'il est ici les
élans pour toi vous font confiance à
gagny ce groupe ça l'isi il fait même
temps nous nous pensons que la ville
manque d'événements festifs et quand le
maire cite la fête d'automne elle elle
n'a de fait que le nom puisque en fait
c'est une c'est une simple foire au troc
com le marché de noël c'est un
commercial
nous nous voulons d'abord créer des
journées citoyennes au cours desquelles
les les habitants pourront participer à
l'entretien des parcs municipaux par
exemple nous voulons créer un 14 juillet
citoyens un grand pique nique ou qui
frappent permettra aux élans courtois de
re découvrir les espaces verts de la
ville
nous avons une magnifique école de
musique à elancourt que nous devons à la
municipalité de jean michel fourgous
mais comme par hasard il n'y a aucune
note de musique dans l'est dans la ville
à la fête de la musique
donc nous créerons une fête nous une
fête de la musique
nous voulons voilà développer les
événements festifs qui crée des liens
entre les gens c'est très important ça
monsieur fau rousse il faut absolument
créer des liens entre les générations
les habitants des lampes moi et m'a
appris quelque chose aujourd'hui parlons
des différentes générations des plus
jeunes à présent éducation quels sont
vos positions aux uns et aux autres ont
ces locaux a été cité plusieurs fois
comme référence sur le développement du
numérique ça s'est développé à
l'ensemble de l'agglomération est ce
qu'il faut s'arrêter là on faire plus
revenir dessus
vos différentes propositions aux uns et
aux autres michel rossi on débute avec
vous alors l'éducation j'ai moi même je
me suis occupé très longtemps en
entreprise de la formation de
l'apprentissage et c'est donc oui
diversifier les modes d'apprentissage ça
apporte toujours un plus mais après il
faut une utilisation plus que raisonnée
du numérique
soyons clair ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que quand vous interrogez des
directeurs d'école ou des parents
d'élèves donc
et là je pense que la plupart des
parents vont s'y retrouver on vous dit
mais c'est pas le numérique qui rend
plus intelligent plus performant ça peut
attirer des enfants qui ont du mal à
prendre autrement ça peut attirer les
enfants qui ont besoin d'une vitesse
d'apprentissage différentes de leurs
petits camarades
ça oui mais est-ce que c'est utile de
donner une tablette à chaque élève
non la remise des prix avec des
connexions sur des livres des
bibliothèques en fin du cm2 je vous dis
il vaudrait mieux leur donner des
informations sur les packs jeunesse sur
la carte et la jeunesse ça leur serait
beaucoup plus utile quand vous
interrogez a posteriori les parents de
ces enfants ils vous disent de toute
façon ils n'en font rien après vous
regardez un certain nombre de nous
regarder un certain nombre de lectures
de personnes je dirais autorisée sur le
sujet
numérique je vais citer la silicon
valley qui je crois une chère à monsieur
fourgous qui monsieur moati vous dit
j'attire votre attention qu'il y a
aujourd'hui un mouvement inverse sur les
tablettes dans les écoles que les écoles
privées de la silicon valley interdit
les écrans dans les écoles y compris
éventuellement conseille aux parents de
ne pas mettre des écrans à disposition
des enfants à leur domicile
donc certes il peut y avoir des avancées
il ne faut pas rejeter tous les outils
encore faut-il savoir bien les utiliser
et votre cerveau il va pas fonctionner
différemment parce que vous apprenez
face à un écran 4 imperatore fast c'est
à vous je leur dis vous avez du temps de
retard là l'écart se creuse forcément
fait en mesure d'aider question
néanmoins je vous passe la parole jauger
sur la taille de vos réponses
mais nous on en sorte que ce soit
équilibré en fonction du temps que
chacun prenne à répondre aux siens
effectivement la municipalité
d'elancourt à dépenser un demi million
pour fournir 2200 tablettes aux élans
courtois aux enfants ils encourent toi
en tant que médecin je suis d'accord sur
le fait qu' il faut une utilisation
raisonnée des tablettes à l'école pour
les enfants
nous savons que les jeunes enfants ont
un développement qui est altéré par
l'abus des écrans cela entraîne et je le
vois dans ma pratique de médecins cela
entraîne des retards de langage des
troubles de la motricité fine des
problèmes attentionnel voilà donc je
pense que sans vouloir retourner au
moyen-âge un pool de tablettes dans une
classe pour être suffisant pour utiliser
certains logiciels pédagogiques qui sont
très intéressants mais il n'est
nullement nécessaire que chaque enfant
est une tablette à lui nous voulons
rétablir une aide aux devoirs proposé
par des encadrants humains et non pas
une aide aux devoirs en ligne
parce que nous savons que ce sont
toujours les mêmes qui vont aller en
ligne pour profiter de l'aide aux
devoirs alors que ce ne sont pas
forcément ceux qui ont le plus besoin
des devoirs nous soutiendrons des
projets entre les associations et les
écoles par exemple créer des potagers
dans chaque école dans lesquelles
pourront venir les les habitants qui ont
des jardins familiaux venir travailler
avec les enfants sur les potagers
ça c'est très intéressant pour
développer le sens écologique des
enfants et développer des liens entre
les associations et les jeunes nous nous
serons très vigilants à lutter contre le
harcèlement à l'école et dans les temps
périscolaires les temps périscolaires
d'ailleurs nous les réaménagerons nous
créeront également une centrale d'achat
pour les fournitures scolaires parce que
ça coûte très cher aux parents les
fournitures scolaires et nous pouvons
améliorer cela par une centrale des
chats nous verrons la qualité des repas
dans les cantines
nous verrons à ce que les repas soient
davantage bio davantage en circuit court
il faut savoir que maintenant les repas
dans les cantines à elancourt viennent
de rouen
donc ça ça n'est pas du tout quelque
chose ni d'écologie cnid rationnelle
voilà pour les lots différentes
propositions vous avez rattrapé ce temps
de retard jean michel fourgous et c'est
à vous concernant l'éducation si vous
voulez revenir répondre à ce qui a été
dit
exposé aussi vos propositions et mes
joies des communautés est original parce
que elle en plus elle a dit qu' elle
voulait à partir des jardins jardin
d'elancourt faire produire la nourriture
et la préparation des repas pour les
écoles bon moi je trouve ça original
jouve ont fléchi que j'ai pas du tout
vous dire on n'en est pas là mais vous
l'avez dit dans un autre moment tout cas
je ne sais quoi parce qu'on parle ces
sortes et des postures où il suffit de
dire je suis de gauche je suis
anticapitaliste écologiste pour dire
voyez j'ai j'ai les solutions
franchement je crois que l'un des grands
leaders du monde écologique guillon il
ne supporte plus et peu sûr il faut il
faut être plus précis de toute façon si
vous si vous ya déjà dédé dans les repas
élan courrier de jeunes participent bio
avec eux un court 6 mandé des points
d'achat vous le souhaitez mais si vous
fait rêver les gens en disant que vous
allez faire à elancourt vous allez
pouvoir créer un service pour un demi
million il ya presque un an et demi en
droit par an bon voilà fou faut être
sérieux c'est tout vous êtes vous fait
rêver c'est bien mais voilà alors le
numérique le numérique d'abord les los
angeles où s francisco vous avez un
certain nombre de faits qui il ce type
ce n'est pas vrai il ya quelques gens
qui ont dit ça c'est pas toutes les
écoles qui ont défini une rixe à cela il
ya une école il n'ya rien écouté ce fou
s'il s'agit des écoles privées la
silicon valley
oui mais s'étend entre eux entre entre
los angeles et san francisco j'avais
loupé deux états aux états unis qui sont
en net repli ce qu'ils ont à dire bien
que j'aimerais que vous me demandez le
numérique
il y à l'éducation nationale française
c'est comme le commissariat moi je
voterai élue miss à l'intérieur je
travaillais et tous les maires de
l'agglo va vous arriver que des bons
faire on va vers l'ailleurs bourg très
bien mais l'éducation à elles viennent
de mettre leur centre de formation pour
4000 gens mais 4000 prof à elancourt
d'être humains d'ailleurs de l'usaj de
cette maison de quartier pour les élans
courtois dit le dites le à l'éducation
nationale mais je pense que je vous
rappelle que le budget doute que
l'éducation nationale et das le budget
la révélation de la mairie c'est 50 pour
cent cinquante ans du jeu de mérite plus
mène d'ailleurs éclairage c'est pas loin
de 60 c'est pour l'éducation la première
compétence qu'on vous donne quand vous
êtes maire c'est celle là donc c'est la
priorité
non si vous dites que les maisons de
quartier bien sûr car ils ont marqué il
faut qu'elles existent pour les
développer il faut bien sûr les
entretiens blessure mais le vous avez
reçu trente ans après c'est moi terminer
vous avez 35 prix et long cours à 35
prix bon c'est une des villes les plus
couronnés par les prix vous êtes le
modèle éducatif français aujourd'hui à
partir du primaire et non pas nous fait
une confusion avec la maternelle je
pense on ne met pas tout le monde est la
créature on ne donne pas une tablette
par enfant elle matin c'est à partir du
primaire deuxièmement vous avez vous
êtes en train de concert nous sommes en
train de construire le m haïti français
avec paris saclay ce qu'entraîne ce
faire votre université vous avez d'avoir
pour vos enfants ou petits-enfants bon
c'est la première université
scientifique
vous allez dire demain le collège aussi
mais les les lycées s'y mettent et vous
allez dire moi je suis contre contre le
numérique contre les tablettes contre
contre la transformation du modèle bd
que je vous ai vu des gens bizarres à
pilsen mais les résultats de la france
qui plonge mais il faut réagir et c'est
le numérique qui va nous aider
l'éducation par le numérique est l'outil
le plus puissant pour charger le monde à
les voir en afrique
comment comment ils n'ont pas de livres
mais en même temps et au cours ont fait
que ses ennuis ont fait on fait plein de
choses mais il faut pas il faut pas dire
que c'est pas 100% mais vous n'avez pas
commencer à vous mobiliser contre la
chose qui quitte une vraie révolution
c'est elancourt qui a participé avec
l'éducation nationale avec des pays
étrangers qui viennent voir ils
encourent ya plein de pays plein
d'exemples
si vous commencez à être contre ça
contre le lait
gigi ou contre le commissariat contre
les piscines je regrette jean-michel
fourgous voilà pour le temps de parole
ya beaucoup de thématiques n'ont pas le
temps d'aborder puisque nous sommes
quasiment à la fin de cette émission est
de rester moins de dix minutes
il y avait le transport la santé aussi
que nous avions prévu d'aborder
l'écologie l'environnement je vais
regrouper tout ça malheureusement dans
une question peut-être un peu plus large
et vous demander à chacun de nous
exposer à quoi ressemblera et long cours
demain pour vous sur ces différentes
thématiques soit le sentais que ce soit
transport que ce soit l'environnement
aussi catherine perrotin questions est
large je sais je suis très sensible
évidemment au sujet de la santé et à
l'accès aux soins de santé pour tout le
monde donc nous allons proposer une
mutuelle de village qui permettra à tous
ceux qui ne peuvent pas actuellement
bénéficier d'une mutuelle
c'est à dire les retraités les chômeurs
les étudiants les indépendants de
pouvoir adhérer à une mutuelle qui
correspond à une qui répondent à une
charte éthique et qui répondra à un
cahier des charges qui sera décidé par
la municipalité qui s'engagera à une
proximité à des tarifs attractifs
nous allons faire en sorte de favoriser
l'installation de jeunes médecins à
elancourt en leur offrant dans des
locaux adaptés avec un bail individuelle
et attractif
nous allons développer une maison de
santé parce que monsieur fourgous n'a
pas du tout compris que la démographie
médicale est telle que les élans
courtois donc elle dans très peu de
temps en fait n'auront plus la
possibilité d'avoir un médecin traitant
là
[Musique]
l'attitude de la mairie vis-à-vis du
dernier médecin qui reste à la clé de
saint pierre est très significative ce
médecin actuellement et dans peut-être
dans quelques jours va décider de partir
parce que la mairie n'a pas su lui
proposer un bail viable pour lui dans
l'âme et de nouvelles maisons de santé
dont il s'est glorifié sur son bilan de
2019 ensuite nous voulons aussi
travailler avec les médecins d'elancourt
sur la possibilité de créer et peut-être
dans les mets dans les locaux de la
nouvelle maison de santé que nous allons
créer une maison médicale de permanence
de soins maison médicale de garde
j'ai été moi même avec des collègues de
la ville nouvelle à l'origine de la
maison médicale de garde qui existe à
montigné actuellement qui est un modèle
pour la france entière depuis 20 ans
donc je sais de quoi je parle et joue je
serais vraiment à l'initiative de ce
projet avec des médecins volontaires
dans et l'encours jean michel fourgous
objets vous fait réagir par rapport à ce
qui était dit oui interpellé sur la
question d'accès saint-pierre juste sur
cette question là et ensuite michel
rossi devrait avoir un jeu se cassa
médecin qui me sens très compliqué aucun
médecin ne veut malheureusement les
travailler avec lui les activités m'ont
compliqué alors on lui et nous on lui
agression matin on a on à coup on est on
lui a construit un cabinet à ce garçon
avec sept bureaux de pour 7,7 cabinet
weil pour ça lui coûte moins de 200
euros par mois vous imaginez le pdk 120
cas empêcher les médecins que vouloir
s'y installe ce studio installé le baril
perdant à ses réponses à cette question
rapidement qu'elle soit et ça lui coûte
je crois donc moins de 1500 pour les 7
bureaux par mois maintenant il demande
un niveau d'exigence moment il veut où
il veut
cette place il veut la place des
policiers gratuit x mais mais où ils ont
vraiment pu plus personne
veut en parler mais dans mon équipe donc
on va passer ça à la à l'ordre des
médecins ils vont gérer ça moi je ne
suis pas compétent pour gérer l'après
vente selon ce cabinet si vous avez
alesi on va passer sa l'ordre des
médecins je viens moi moi je vois qu'ils
tendent la clé saint pierre sur ce sujet
et il peut exercer il faut néanmoins
blague que nous a coûté deux points
d'impôt 200 250 mille euros c'est de
penser que vous me connaissez pas les
chicanes faire autant jean michel
fourgous s'il vous plaît à tous les deux
c'est michel rossi sait que des déchets
alors si c'est à vous à quoi ressemblera
pour vous la ville de demain
elle encourt la ville de demain est en
cours je dirai juste deux mots sur
l'aspect santé
je rappelle que elancourt n'est plus
attractive qu'il encoure perd un point
chaque année de population nous sommes
un peu moins de 25 mille habitants
aujourd'hui que la population vieillit
nous avons mieux nous avons pris dépend
quel site on regarde nous avons augmenté
la population des 60 ans et plus de 3
points donc c'est un vrai souci à
prendre en compte
ça veut dire que nous avons déjà annoncé
nous dans notre programme que nous
ouvrirons une maison de santé au 7 mars
il y a les possibilités en immeuble
triton et nous allons nous y attacher
j'ai pour cela ait changé aussi bien
avec les médecins ou cette marque avec
les médecins du centre claude bernard
qu'avec également le docteur novillo à
la clé s'inquiète donc nous souhaitons
maintenir ces maisons de santé non
d'ouvrir une supplémentaire d'autres
relations la vente et sur la surface
très bien entendu environnementale là il
ya un gros travail à faire nous serons
vigilants à redresser l'état du
patrimoine nous engagerons avec l'ademe
un diagnostic de l'ensemble des
bâtiments
on les mettre aux normes et les
restaurer on voit que lionel terray lors
de sa construction pour un coût quand
même 2 5 millions 3 qui reste à la
charge des élans courtois a eu des
défauts au moment de sa construction
donc je pense que nous aurons quelques
soucis prochainement avec des fuites
nous allons passer aux conclusions
de ce débat les uns et les autres en
essayant d'équilibrer au mieux tout cela
catherine perrotin
non c'est avec eux pour ne pas me
tromper sur l'ordre de la conclusion
excusez moi c'est michel rossi qui va
conclure l'ordre inverse de tout à
l'heure nous tiennent aussi vous avez
votre conclusion
vous avez deux minutes si vous souhaitez
les prendre pour conclure alors
clairement nous nous présentons comme
une alternative à ce fameux dilemme
entre eux ne se font au bout ce qui est
maire depuis un quart de siècle et les
listes de gauche qui n'ont
malheureusement pour elle jamais réussi
à l'emporter
nous sommes une liste citoyenne ce qui
nous préoccupe aujourd'hui c'est l'état
de la ville c'est de prendre en compte
ce quotidien pour emmener la ville vers
demain
ça veut dire que nous allons travailler
sur trois axes je le redis la démocratie
l'attractivité de la ville et tout ce
qui est environnemental
nous sommes à la disposition des
habitants pour avancer avec eux sur ces
sujets là pour votre conclusion je
rappelle que vous avez un peu plus de
temps je vous laisser le temps mais vous
avez conclu
et c'est à vous catherine perrotin pour
la conclusion vous avez une minute
trente minutes 45 pour conclure
réinventons elancourt pense que les
élans courtois mérite mieux qu'un mais
refusé par 24 ans de mandature
la mère qui n'a plus aucune idée
nouvelle pour la ville et qui la gère
comme une entreprise
le maire actuel est passionné de
nouvelles technologies mais il en oublie
qu'il a affaire à des êtres humains
il diffuse une communication qui est de
la propagande et pas du tout de
l'information il parle de ses réseaux
mais c'est une vision d'une autre époque
qui peut encore penser qu'on ne peut
travailler qu'avec ses amis il n'est pas
présent dans la ville il n'y habite pas
ils ne consultent pas les habitants sur
ses projets
les élans courtois mérite une mère qui
vit dans la ville qui écoute les
habitants qui les entend qui répondent à
leurs courriers qui est proche d'eux sur
le terrain une mer qui engagent des
projets en concertation avec les
habitants
une mère qui
c'est travailler en équipe une mère qui
ne vit pas de la politique
il mérite enfin une mère dont la
priorité sera le bien-être et la santé
des élans courtois jean-michel votre
conclusion ou 7 secondes quand on n'est
pas aisé qualif pas plus beau si vous ne
tiendrez pas alors management il faut
être beaucoup plus positif que ça
surtout pour gérer les gens 2 mais cela
dit alors non kepu démocratie bon père
de marié sur les pas de problème non
mettre tout ça en place
mais on y compte là on est contre mais
même le même le fameux pont david yeux
qui était très difficile bien non qui
sont content que contre le comice à
contres mais comment voulez vous que les
gens vous fassent confiance 50% des des
besoins financer que vous aviez soins
extérieurs deux allèles les chercher si
vous arrivez avec une approche aussi
négative aussi destructives même ça veut
dire que vous aimez peu votre ville
alors vous dites que j'habite pas
d'abord c'est faux j'ai un appartement à
paris depuis trente ans vous le savez
mes enfants sont à paris c'est vrai que
j'échange beaucoup entre paris et
l'encours jeunes appartenant au chu le
propriétaire on le sait très bien
pourquoi vous dites pas c'est toujours
c'est toujours les calomnies toutes vos
de campagne c'était la calomnie mon
hockey bon voilà maintenant il faut être
sérieux
yann est temps de forte c'est un modèle
elancourt c'est pour ça qu'on lui a
confié aussi la présidence de 50 à vous
devriez vous en apercevoir c'est pas si
c'est aussi négatif pour presque tous
ses gens nous ont donné pouvoir sauver
tout le monde nous fait confiance que ce
soit larcher que ce choix pécresse que
ce soit bédié l'ensemble de même paris
saclay un je peux vous dire il n'ya pas
le même discours sur l encours surtout
surtout surtout de vous voir si ce livre
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce débat les temps paroles qui
s'affichent une dernière fois la
campagne va se poursuivre jusqu'au date
du premier tour sera le 15 mars et nous
aurons l'occasion de vous recevoir les
uns et les autres pour évoquer vos
programmes et venir vous voir sur vos
différentes rencontres et meetings
la campagne se poursuit aussi sur notre
antenne elle est à suivre dans le
journal quotidien chaque soir à 18
heures à bientôt sur tv soixante dix
huit pour un nouveau débat
[Musique]